si Neptune connaît ton
désir alors je le mettrai
de côté Je chevauche un
hippocampe dans ton
eau jusqu'à ce que nous soyons brisés dans
Wild
parce que tu es
tout
connu si seulement je pouvais te voir
ce rêve ne serait pas
si
difficile si seulement je pouvais
te voir  ce rêve ne serait pas oh si très
dur ouais ça
t'appelle dans
tout ce qui est
connu
si les étoiles filantes te font te
demander alors maintenant nous allons peindre le ciel
toute
la journée toute la journée ouais pour que nous puissions planer Li
ensemble oh j'adore tomber  c'est
lourd
parce que si seulement
je pouvais te voir,
ce
rêve ne serait pas si
difficile
si seulement je pouvais te voir,
ce rêve ne serait pas
oh si très dur
ouais, vous
tout
savez, tout le monde
sait tout
cela, vous et tout ce que vous
savez W
non
parce que